Beach week came late this year but
Christmas has come early with the
confirmation of Brett Kavanaugh to the
Supreme Court on Saturday afternoon a
joyous occasion all around with beer and
Boo f---ing galore we will examine what
conservatives should learn from this
wonderful turn of events then socialist
Looney tune Alexandria Ocasio Cortez
says nothing at all the New York Times
attacks white women white woman Bette
Midler calls herself the n-word and
Christopher Columbus discovers America
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael no leo
[Music]
mm-hmm you know I wish this were beer
instead of flavored seltzer water
but unfortunately the Taylor wire didn't
have any beer and its rich nevertheless
I think this can stand in to celebrate
for associate Supreme Court justice
Brett Kavanaugh mmm I wonder if anyone
can shotgun a seltzer water I don't
think that's possible this is a huge day
we have so much to talk about
if I weren't plugged in I would get up
on my desk and dance on top of it before
we do that I've got some extremely
exciting news today the daily wire has
launched the next chapter in Andrew
clavin's podcast series another Kingdom
performed by little ol me Michael
Knowles today and on every following
Monday subscribers to the daily wire
will be able to watch new episodes of
season two if you are not a subscriber
you will have to wait until Friday to
watch new episodes and only the first 15
minutes will be available to the public
as a video so what are you waiting for
everybody gets the audio eventually but
only the first 15 minutes will be
available as a video in addition to my
dramatic reading this season we have
added a dramatic visual component you
will not want to miss here is a clip
from the first episode of season 2 then
finally it was dark time to go with the
locket still in my hand I rolled off the
bed there was nothing to pack I had
nothing with me I ditched my phone so no
one could trace me I'd stopped at an ATM
near La to stock up on cash I couldn't
use credit cards they could trace those
two i dismantled the GPS in my car no
internet no social media I was invisible
and I was utterly alone I crossed the
Pitt brown carpet to the door I opened
the door onto the night outside there
was billiard ball he stood gigantically
on the threshold framed in the doorway
with the parking lot lights glaring
behind him before I could react he
jabbed me in the neck with a stun gun
the electric blast sent me reeling back
into the room convulsing down to the
floor
I dropped to the carpet jerking and
shuddering my muscles were locked up in
mobile all I could do was lie there and
judder and watch his billiard ball
stepped calmly into the room and calmly
shut the door behind him
enormous shoulders were packed into a
leather jacket his muscles bulged
through the thin sweater he wore
underneath he looked down at my
quivering body without a smile without a
sneer without any emotion at all he
hardly seemed interested in what he saw
he reached into his jacket and slid the
little stun gun into his left inside
pocket
then he reached across into his right
inside pocket and drew out a small
leather case terror exploded inside me
as I watched him unzip the case and
deftly remove a syringe I made a
horrible helpless gurgling noise in my
throat as I battled to get control of my
body it was no use
my muscles had been severed from my will
I tell you I I have the easiest job in
the whole thing because I just go there
and read the story and do the voices the
artwork if you couldn't see it if you're
just listening the artwork is so good
and the story is really good so I
encourage you to head over to daily wear
that come subscribe watch both the first
and second seasons of another Kingdom
soo much to get to who do we thank first
for this Brett Kavanaugh thing and I'm
actually going to contradict
conservative orthodoxy but first let me
make a little money honey what's more
conservative than that expressvpn with
all the recent news about online
security breaches it's hard not to worry
about where your data goes making an
online purchase or simply accessing your
email could put your private information
at risk we've just found out that China
has been spying and in all of our
technology has in the biggest servers in
the country seriously you would be
insane to even check your email if
you're not using a VPN you're being
tracked by social media sites marketing
companies your mobile and Internet
provider use Express VPN protect your
privacy it secures and anonymizes your
internet browsing by encrypting your
data and hiding your public IP address
protect yourself with expressvpn cost
less than seven bucks a month protect
your online activity today find out how
you can get three months free at
expressvpn comm / michael mi CH AE l
expr ESS VPN comm / michael mi CH AE l
that is three months free with a
one-year package visit expressvpn
dot-com / Michael to learn more and
protect your privacy I know what you're
thinking conservatives you're thinking
can
Serbs are supposed to be doer we're
supposed to be pessimistic we're
supposed to be sad we're always supposed
to be angry and upset you know because
the culture is falling away and the West
is decaying but it not today not today
with the confirmation the confirmation a
brick Avenue it is hard to imagine how
this could have turned out any better
than it did it just turned out so well
did noise have to Pretty Reckless game
pretty risky Jeff Flake could have
screwed it all up for us could have
wrecked the Supreme Court wrecked our
electoral chances but that's not how it
worked out so who can we thank for this
who can we thank for being the
conscience of a conservative and being
the backbone of the GOP Susan Collins
Lindsey Graham Bowe cocaine Mitch
McConnell and Donald Trump if you had
told me three years ago that the
conscience of a conservative would be
certainly Trump who knew the Trump was
gonna be a Republican Susan Collins
Lindsey Graham Mitch McConnell I would
have laughed in your face but they stood
up they were the backbone of the GOP and
actually the GOP is a moral conscience
here by saying no we're not gonna let
you destroy Brett Kavanaugh we're not
gonna let you assassinate his character
based on nothing based on less than
nothing based on smears that have fallen
apart time and time again we're not
gonna let you do it and Susan Collins
articulated this beautifully in a speech
that I hope the entire country was
watching probably they won't because she
really came into the room and
articulated what was so wrong with those
proceedings
I found her testimony to be sincere
painful and compelling I believe that
she is a survivor of a sexual assault
nevertheless
the four witnesses she named could not
corroborate any of the events of that
evening gathering I do not believe that
the claims such as these need to be
proved beyond a reasonable doubt
nevertheless fairness would dictate that
the Clay
at least should meet a threshold of more
likely than not duh yeah of course I
mean thank you for putting it that way
it's true it's not a criminal proceeding
although the Democrats certainly were
treating it as one so sure it doesn't
need to be beyond a reasonable doubt but
at least more likely than not at least
she should the the accusers should try
to keep their story straight for more
than five minutes at a time not get
caught in a multitude of lies yeah of
course you shouldn't ruin a man's career
with a decade of unquestioned integrity
as a federal judge before that staff
secretary to the president
deputy independent counsel under the
Starr investigation the guy has an
unimpeachable track record you don't get
to ruin that guy's life just cuz just
because you want to so we have to thank
Susan Collins we also have to thank the
Democrats who filibustered Neil Gorsuch
because this caused a cocaine Mitch to
go nuclear on Neil Gorsuch people forget
this they get a little confused on what
the nuclear option means where you know
the nuclear option was first invoke by
Harry Reid he invoked it in 2013 because
he wanted to ram through more of Barack
Obama's judges at the lower level so he
said nope we no longer need a 60-vote
majority to confirm judges we're gonna
bring that down to a simple majority as
long as you get a simple majority that's
fine we can confirm the judges and
44-year senators had talked about doing
this but they always backed away because
they knew that when they're out of power
this is a very bad thing and but Harry
Reid said I don't care I'm ramming
Obama's judges through that's fine
cocaine Mitch what are your thoughts on
that
once again Senate Democrats are
threatening to break the rules of the
Senate break the rules of the Senate in
order to change the rules of the Senate
and over what over what over a court
that doesn't even have enough work to do
the majority leader promised he promised
over and over again that he wouldn't
break the rules of the Senate in order
to change them you want to play
James set yet another precedent that
you'll no doubt come to regret say to my
friends on the other side of the aisle
you'll regret this and you may regret it
a lot sooner than you think
you're gonna regret him my little
friends on the other side of the aisle
you're gonna regret him my little
friends a lot sooner than you think a
lot sooner ha ha
that's a cocaine Mitch McConnell in 2013
prophetic words totally prophetic words
because then when it came up with Neil
borage don't forget a lot of Democrats
during this Kavanagh circus have said
well little Kavanagh is just a bad guy
look we weren't this bad about Neil
Gorsuch first of all yes you were you
tried to filibuster him but second of
all the reason they didn't create a
hullabaloo and accuse him of gang rape
in the 80s is because Neil Gorsuch was
replacing Scalia he was replacing the
original astouch so it didn't swing the
balance of the court who knows actually
if Gorsuch is as rock-ribbed as Scalia
time will tell so it didn't change the
balance of the court now that you're
replacing Anthony Kennedy the swing vote
who sided with the left of the court on
very important matters you know like the
gay marriage decision a bird fell for
example when you when you're replacing
that guy it's much different because
then you'll actually have a conservative
majority an originalist majority on the
court so they went after them he goes
they go after Gorsuch they filibuster
Gorsuch from Mitch McConnell says well
remember when I said that you were gonna
regret this sooner than you think
it's and now it's sooner than you think
so he did it he went nuclear for Supreme
Court nominees and that's how we were
able to get a judge Kavanagh through
it's a great great turn of events for us
that actually didn't hinge on this
nomination it was on the last one so
that's great we can thank the Democrats
who filibustered too we should also not
forget by the way future Democratic
presidential nominee Michael avenatti
you know the creepy porn lawyer the
creepy porn where played an integral
role in this because he exposed the
Democrats strategy of just finding
random unfalsifiable unverifiable
allegations from 50,000 years ago he
exposed it because he did it in his
avenatti way you know Diane
einstein dipper Katz they were a little
more subtle when they when they dragged
up Christine Ford and at the eleventh
hour after the hearings were over leaked
her complaint to the Senate Judiciary
Committee they were a little more subtle
christina ford is a more subtle
character when it got to Julie sweat
McMichael a vanadis client you know
she's accusing him of being like a
leather daddy gang rapists crime boss in
the 80s that one seems so ridiculous the
New York Times agrees they wrote quote
the tides seemed to turn oddly enough
when a third woman emerged with even
more extreme allegations
Michael avenatti a brash and media savvy
California lawyer who has been careening
from one Trump administration brushfire
to another produced a statement from a
woman alleging that Judge Cavanaugh in
high school attended parties where women
were gang raped the woman Julie sweat
Nick said she herself was gang raped at
one such party though not by the judge
and the woman kept going to the parties
for some reason very not a very smart
woman apparently if if any of those
allegations had even the whiff of truth
to them which obviously they do not Alan
Dershowitz agrees with this famed
liberal lawyer Alan Dershowitz he
tweeted this out he said Cavanaugh owes
an enormous debt to michael avenatti who
may have turned the tide in his favor by
diluting ford's compelling accusation
with an implausible story now he uses
that phrase compelling allegation I'm
not convinced by that I don't really see
why the allegation is compelling it came
after 30 years of silence and into a
vague allegation six years ago the first
time Cavanaugh his name was floated and
then it then the story changed a few
different times by the time she wrote to
Dianne Feinstein it changed when she
took the polygraph had changed when she
talked the Washington Post it was
refuted by every person that she claims
was there including her lifelong friend
Leland Kaiser a lady lady Leland Kaiser
it's not just the guys hear a woman
refuted her claims - so I don't really
think it's compelling at all and it
changed a lot nevertheless he's right it
was a much more subtle accusation so you
got to thank you gotta give credit where
credit is due and thank mr. avenatti
for that the other the other group that
you have to thank the other incident
that you have to thank is Ford's
changing
story because if Ford was able to keep
her story straight this probably would
have been a lot stronger even though it
was 36 years after the fact even though
she'd never told anybody about it if she
could have kept the story straight it
probably would have been stronger but
she couldn't keep her story straight
initially it was four boys in the room
then it was two boys in the room then
there were four more people there than
five six seven people there then she
named all the people they refuted her so
then she said okay well there was an
another person who I forget she couldn't
say who drove her there she couldn't say
who drove her home and then she said she
had to she she couldn't testify in
Washington because she was afraid of
flying and that she was afraid of flying
because of confined spaces the fear of
confined spaces stemming from this
incident 36 years ago then it turns out
she flies all over the place flies to
French Polynesia flies to Hawaii fly
stir New Hampshire
flies all over so that doesn't sound
good an ex-boyfriend of hers came out
and said they used to fly in propeller
planes in Hawaii and she never expressed
a fear of flying ever so that part fell
apart as well then she says the
polygraph test was this long long test
it took us she told her whole life story
it was she was so nervous about it then
we find out she knows a lot about
polygraph tests and the polygraph she
took was only two questions and she
volunteered to take it and she and her
team paid the polygraph examiner to give
the test that also didn't hold up very
well then the one I think that finally
cracked it was she said I I had a second
door installed on my home when we
renovated it because I was so afraid of
confined spaces stemming from this 36
year old allegation and this came up
during 2012 marriage counseling session
turns out she filed to get the second
door in 2008 four years earlier for a
marriage counseling office for a room
that she rented out to Google interns
and two college students story just fell
apart which is why I disagree with
professor Dershowitz I don't find it
compelling at all but if that story
hadn't fallen apart I think you'd still
see the Democrats focusing on her they
wouldn't have started talking about
Brett Kavanaugh you know throwing ice at
a New Haven bar so the other thing
that's a little weird about this now and
really diminishes Ford's credibility is
she said she's not going to pursue her
charges any further she initially she
said brick haven't uh not only groped
her but tried to
raper and not only tried to rape her but
almost killed her and now she says no
it's all right now he's on the court I
don't care that's that's a little
strange isn't it and that can be you can
impeach a judge why doesn't she want to
impeach the judge her lawyer Deborah
Katz said that she did not want the
judge impeached that's a little strange
isn't it I wonder why that is
she just well the reason that she
doesn't want the judge impeached is
because now it's not politically
advantageous that's why there's no
what's the advantage now to doing it
there he got through he managed to
squeak through she doesn't want any more
spotlight on her changing story so now
it's over and I think Democrats realize
that it's killing them in the polls so
they think that they have to move on
from this it's I I hope forever we can
retire the word credible you know for
like the next please the next six months
or so but what this really gets to this
was highlighted by a writer for The
Colbert show Ariel Dumas is they don't
care whether Christine Ford story is
true which story would be true I don't
know they don't care about some story
from when he was at Yale and he
allegedly whipped it out at a party that
other people there refute they they
don't care about Julie sweat Nick
certainly they don't care about any of
that what they wanted to do is ruin his
life
and hand it to Ariel Dumas the writer
for the Colbert show she said quote
whatever happens I'm just glad we ruined
Brett Kavanaugh his life cuz that's all
they wanted to do that's all they were
after they didn't like him they didn't
like him because it was an originalist
he's an originalist judge he's gonna
change the balance of the court they
tried all these different tactics they
finally called him a rapist and a nearer
killer and this and event and at least
they ruined his life and that's what
they were really after to ruin this
guy's life for them it reminds me of it
reminds me of the Godfather you know
when they talk about killing and murder
this is this is the Michael Corleone a
theory of judicial confirmations mr.
Corleone II what are your thoughts it's
not personal Sonny it's strictly
business
it's not personal Brett it's not
personal that's my father Brett That's
not me
strictly business you know in the
Godfather Part two Hyman Roth the Lee
Strasberg the Jewish gangster is there
he said this is the business we've
chosen they treat it like business and
then the minute that the deal is over
they move on
so okay sorry we ruined your life but
you know yeah that's business we're not
gonna press we're not gonna pursue these
charges any further we're not gonna try
to impeach you it's just business yeah
right exactly it's just business just
shallow hackish political business
pretty sad the question you have to ask
yourself here is is this the kind of
politics that you want is this do you
want the kind of government where
anybody who's put up for anything has
their lives ruined they have to either
be squeaky clean or even if they are
squeaky clean they're still not good
enough there's still you know if you're
Mitt Romney you're a dog killer gay
bashing whatever and if you're Brett
Kavanaugh who's lived in on
unimpeachable life then you just become
a rapist because of fantasies concocted
out of whole cloth do you really want
this kind of politics no I might suggest
a date and I might suggest at a time
because what you get in this politics is
only the worst people it's only people
who feel no shame this is why Bill
Clinton was so successful in politics is
the Clintons are immune from shame they
cannot feel it
so they accused Bill Clinton of you know
having sexual affairs in the Oval Office
he says I'm telling you I did not have
sexual relations with that woman
what was it a month later two months
later like five seconds after he says
that to the American people he sits down
in that next press conference you said
look I might have had some sexual
relations with her but I'm telling you
the truth now and they just can do that
because he feels no shame
actually this is an advantage sometimes
when it works with Republican candidates
you know President Trump
ran on this he said yep I slept with a
ton of women who weren't my wife
sleeping with my friends wives is one of
the highlights of life and I'm a playboy
billionaire don't care don't worry about
and it really makes you immune from
attacks because they try to attack you
in
Yeah right I wrote about that in my book
Barack Obama did this in his first book
the dreams from my father says yeah I
did a bunch of coke I did a bunch of
blow I smoked a lot of pot I ate a bunch
of dogs and Indonesia I mean he out lays
it pretty clearly he says he paddled
around with Communists and by the end of
the book because he's exposed to
everything to you you're not afraid of
him because you see him and you see is
not an intimidating guy certainly Barack
Obama is not an intimidating guy and so
you don't fear him anymore but you get
you get bad people this way it would be
nice if we could have a little bit more
of you know Washington Hamilton that
would be a enjoy that James Madison John
Adams but you don't get that in a
politics where you are going to truly
ruin somebody's life I'm not I'm not
letting the press off the hook for
something for their treatment of
Democrats over the years where they
would treat the Democrats way nicer
they'd cover up for Democrats they would
it was truly a conspiracy but if you
could have a little bit of an agreement
between the between the Republicans and
the Democrats to say certain things are
off limits
Highschool rumors and yearbooks that's
off limits in the if you you might have
a more respectable politics just a
suggestion but that's not what you're
gonna get so you're only going to get
people who are shameless who are
know-nothings who have nothing to lose
which of course brings us to Alexandria
occasional cortex
I'm stealing Steve Hayward's line
Alexandria occasional cortex she went on
MSNBC over the weekend to give her
agenda if she is elected to Congress and
I don't think I could have said it any
better myself take it away
Alexandria you're going at there's time
when people were talked about how it's
broken and it's so polarized both of
which I think are true and you're also
coming really as an outsider at a moment
where I think people like or watching
what happened today and want to storm
the gates and you're gonna actually do
that so well that's what's what's your
plan well I think a lot of it has to do
with changing our strategy around
governance you know there's a lot of
inside baseball and inside the beltway
as you you know you always hear that
term thrown around but there are very
few organizer
in Congress and I do think that
organizers operate differently it's a
different kind of strategy and what it
is it's really about organizing and and
really thinking about that word
organizing segmenting people being
strategic in their actions in really
bringing together a cohesive strategy of
putting pressure on the chamber instead
of only focusing on the pressures inside
the chamber that's really interesting
thought that was she answered nothing
she didn't say any what did she say zero
but this is why the Democrats have to
revert to brutal passions sex and race
basically and say yeah we have the same
skin color vote for me yeah we we have
the same genitals vote for me when you
have to cuz run run run tits because
they aren't making any arguments they're
not advancing any agenda other than the
the increase of their own power which is
why they're socialists socialism is just
taking power away from people and giving
it to the government and they're doing
they say give me me me me they can't
make an argument for that you can't make
an argument to somebody to give away all
of their freedom and property right you
have to sit you have to appeal to these
base brutal passions and it's really sad
because there isn't a public debate
being had about socialism it's just the
identity politics and the intersectional
politics of the left and this brings us
to not the dumbest article on the
Internet today
this actually transcends that this is a
little higher than that this is the
dumbest article on the internet this
month the award goes to
Alexis Grinnell from the New York Times
the column is white women after a
confirmation process where women all but
no I'm sorry
white women come get your people that
white women come get your people is the
head of it the too long didn't read is
that white women are the cause of all
the problems in the world here's how she
begins after a confirmation process
where women all but slit their wrists
letting their stories of sexual trauma
run like rivers of blood through the
Capitol the Senate still voted to
confirm judge Brett Kavanaugh and I
wonder why men call them hysterical
wonder why they almost slit their wrists
and the trauma of blood I think what you
mean is that George Soros has paid
protesters ran and shrieks throughout
the capital like a bunch of hysterical
children she goes up Alexis cosa with
the exception of Senator Lisa Murkowski
of Alaska all the women in the
Republican Conference caved including
senator Susan Collins of Maine who held
out till the bitter end
these women are gender traders to borrow
a term from the dystopian TV series The
Handmaid's Tale this by the way they can
only reference trashy modern TV shows
because they don't know anything about
literature or history or philosophy so
like oh this is why people you know when
they're discussing myth these days they
can only ever talk about Harry Potter
and Star Wars
that's why Millennials ever talking they
say you're like Dumbledore I don't know
I haven't read Harry Potter since I was
nine but that's all they can reference
because they had they don't have any
other cultural inheritance to draw on so
she says you know to borrow a term from
The Handmaid's Tale to borrow a term
from Family Guy I don't know you're
talking about some trash TV get over you
or you like read a book read a book lady
and then you know you can bring out that
cultural inheritance she goes on they've
made standing by the patriarchy a
standing against the patriarchy by the
patriarchy a full-time job
Senator Lindsey Graham of South Carolina
whose response to a woman telling him
she was raped was I'm sorry
call the cops so the patriarchy thing
we'll get to that in a minute but the
Lindsey Graham Lindsey Graham someone
comes up to him and says I'm where I was
raped what do you expect him to say what
should he say what you should call the
cops
that's a horrible crime that's a heinous
crime you should go to the cop my sister
was murdered like yet have you told the
cops about that they should investigate
then maybe prosecute the guy who did it
find the guy who did it but they're
they're just using it they're they're
just using the claim of sexual assault
which has been defined down to almost
nothing at this point a an unwanted kiss
as a sexual assault some guy comes up to
you at a bar and you're talking and he
tries to kiss you that's a sexual
assault by some definitions and they're
just trying to use that
to weaponize that tomorrow the left's
term to tell Republicans to shut up and
to keep originalist off the court really
pathetic the the article concludes
recently miss Conway even weaponized I
told you there's that word her own
alleged sexual assault in service of her
boss by discouraging women from feeling
empathy with Christine Blasi four-door
anger at judge Kavanagh
she's attacking Kellyanne Conway adviser
to the president for doing exactly the
same thing that the left has been doing
and it seems like she's not even
believing her or she's judging her
skeptically about this really really
dumb column that that just it's just
like the Alexandria Ocasio Cortes of New
York Times columns which is I can't make
an argument I can't advance an argument
I'm relying on facts that simply are not
so I'm relying on fantasies so I am just
going to appeal to brutal instincts and
passions me woman you woman Oh
bad men that me me swarthy you swarthy
us white bad I mean that's basically the
argument that they're making and it's
all of the sophistication of people
whose greatest cultural achievement that
they can draw on is the and maids tale
and by the way a Bette Midler the
performer the singer the actress Bette
Midler really highlighted this very well
last week when she tweeted out a quote
from one of the worst John Lennon songs
she said women are the n-word over the
world women are the n-word of the world
this is from a one of the worst John
Lennon songs that he wrote with Yoko Ono
and the song is one women woman is the
n-word of the world yes she is think
about it if you if your second line is
think about it your first line isn't
that good you know that but just think
about it so that's our woman women are
the n-word of the world raped beaten
enslaved married off work like dumb
animals denied education and inheritance
and during the pain and danger of
childbirth and life in silence for
thousands of years they're the most
disrespected creatures on earth but we
know that those numbers aren't so we
know that that isn't true I think we
talked about this a few days ago
the more men are raped in the United
States than women men are more likely to
suffer fatal injuries on the job men are
much more likely to kill themselves
three and a half times more likely I
think it is true that women are supposed
to be the only ones to give childbirth
but don't forget Planned Parenthood now
says that some men have uterus so I
don't know maybe maybe men can do that
too now it's it's just base passions
that are totally ignorant of reality you
know there are lies damned lies and
statistics sometimes statistics tell you
something about the truth and this is
the lies versus statistics so obviously
that that isn't a good argument going
into November obviously that case isn't
going to work the problem runs so much
deeper than just politics runs so much
deeper than just politics or culture oh
I'm gonna have to say goodbye to
Facebook and YouTube but we've got to
talk about one of the greatest stories
of the last six months it's almost as
good as Brett Kavanaugh being confirmed
to the Supreme Court which is that
grievance studies you know women's
studies and African American Studies and
this studies and that studies are these
hoaxers were able to get journals
serious academic journals to publish
their hoax articles just using random
left-wing buzzwords and they were able
to get them through because grievin
studies are forest and most of
university campuses are farcical at this
point we will get to some of the
highlights of that and we've got to talk
about how great christopher columbus's
but only if you go to daily wire.com if
you're on facebook and youtube
head on over you got to do it plus now
you get another kingdom out of it this
is a good deal you get to hear another
kingdom and see another kingdom days and
days early go to daily wire.com why you
know you get all the shows you get to
ask questions in the mailbag you get to
ask questions in the conversation here
it is here it is folks this is gonna be
a long beach week if you don't have a
leftist ears tumblr this is going to be
PJ and squee are going to be the only
ones who survive when you drown in those
leftist tears that have been unleashed
because by the way we're just
celebrating today that they
I got on the court what happens when I
don't know some Chevron difference cases
come up oh is that not sexy enough for
you how about some cases that get to the
legality and constitutionality of
abortion hmm what happens then are
you're going you're gonna lift a hundred
leftist tears tumbler kegs over your
head in celebration of this wonderful
achievement of ours of this wonderful
fuff of a frickin achievement it's gonna
be really really good go to daily
wire.com we'll be right back with a lot
more and a celebration of Christopher
Columbus
the grievance studies thing is so
wonderful one you know that there's
women's gender and sexuality studies
ethnicity race and migration studies
african-american studies this isn't that
and you know all of the grievant studies
majors really like the thing that
they're aggrieved about you know so they
really like gender studies they really
like women you know women and Gender
Studies African American Studies is
really complimentary of the
contributions of African Americans the
only one that this is not true for is
American Studies which is a discipline
devoted to denigrating America in
literature and history all over the
place
so I really like this because when I was
in college in shortly after college I
was running a blog with a buddy of mine
where we would just take out quotes from
peer-reviewed Gender Studies journals
that are so absurd on their face and we
would put them up I think it's still up
there I think it's at Gender Studies
department - blog tumblr com I believe
they still have it up it was so they
would talk about things like vegetarian
ecofeminism z' and the role of the
werewolf is queer pederast in the harry
potter they had a book called query
elementary education which i think is a
crime I'm not sure I haven't checked out
the federal laws recently but I think
that's a crime or queering the non /
human and it just like total nonsense so
these guys their names are helen pluck
Rose James Lindsay and Peter Bogosian
have contributed nonsense articles to
grievance studies journals and they've
gotten them published so one paper which
was published in the journal called sex
roles said that the author had conducted
a two-year study involving thematic
analysis of table dialogue to uncover
the mystery of why heterosexual men
would like to eat at Hooters so just
just picture that image of what that two
year study is I think I've done that -
your study actually I've probably done
that study for about 15 years and I'm
I'm really getting to the heart of why
men like to eat at Hooters another one
of these was from the feminist geography
Journal I don't know what separate
actually I could make a few jokes here
but they're not really that nice to
think about I guess there could be a
feminist geographer use your imagination
it parsed thee quote human reactions to
rape culture and queer performativity at
dog parks in Portland Portland Oregon
the human reaction to rape culture at
dog parks and and you know if you've
ever been to a dog park I think you can
see a lot of heteronormativity there
although I don't know sometimes dogs
have come up to me to a my my my leg is
an example of some of the non
heteronormativity maybe that the canines
can exhibit and and then there was
another one it was published in Journal
of feminist social work this is the best
one of all it was titled
our struggle is my struggle and what it
did is it scattered left-wing ideology
and little left-wing terms into a
rewriting of Hitler's mind comp because
mine comp means my struggle it's the the
book as our struggle is my struggle and
just changes it around a little bit
really excellent work guys I got to tell
you something when I published that
blank book I thought that I would get to
be the the troll door in chief for a
little while Helen pluck Rose James
Lindsey Peter Bogosian my hat goes off
to you it's really wonderful because it
it really shows the universities for
what they are and especially these
departments for what they are one
question that people are asking is
whether we should abandon the
universities at this point if they're
just so far gone that there's no way to
get them back I don't think so at all I
don't think so at all that's what the
left wants us to think these people you
know who read about or how our struggle
is my struggle and the heteronormativity
of dog parks they they want us to
believe it's a lost cause and to abandon
the universities they wanted us to do
that to the mainstream media in the 80s
and 90s oh we should why would we have a
conservative
News Channel no no no one wants that no
one would watch that cut to the 1990s
Fox News becomes one of the biggest
names and news the biggest cable news
network by far
same thing in public policy remember
they told us in 2015-2016 Republicans
give it up
it's Hillary's turn she's gonna win
there's no way there's no way Trump
could win he can't win don't even vote
don't even go you're not look we're not
we're gonna get Hillary or and get some
left-wing judges they're gonna get rid
of the first and second amendment but
what you can't do anything and then we
all just did something and then it
worked
I think they I've mentioned this theory
before the left is like the opposite of
sand people they don't hide their
numbers they exaggerate their numbers
they like it's like one person just hops
left and right left and right makes it
seem like there are a lot of them I
think the majority of the American
people have a basic conservatism lower
sea conservatism maybe it doesn't
totally line up with Edmund Burke or
John Locke or whatever but there is a
basic conservatism to the American
people and when you give them the
opportunity to watch Fox News or you
give them the opportunity to see
conservatives through a new media daily
wire is a good example of this they're
going to do it there you're going to get
huge ratings we need huge numbers people
just want the opportunity same thing in
public policy when you give them the
opportunity to vote for building a wall
hopefully we're gonna get that wall
sometime soon but it not to enforce
immigration laws to deport people who
should be deported to get serious about
those things to care to care about the
American worker try to protect American
jobs to get serious about our enemies
abroad to get serious about the economy
just institute a pro-growth deregulation
agenda basic things when you give them
that opportunity even in the package of
Donald Trump who has a lot of flaws to
him they're gonna go for that there's a
lot or a lot more people out there you
know the the left the line was always in
the 1970s the media would write that so
I don't I don't know a single person who
voted for Richard Nixon Nixon won in a
landslide twice so I don't know a single
person who voted for Donald Trump a lot
of people out there and there's a demand
for this at colleges there's a demand
when conservative speakers come to
campus which I you know I get to
participate in that I get to go to
campuses too when groups request that me
and
people like me come and speak there
there's a huge demand at think tanks
there's a huge demand for summer
programs I've gone to great programs
Hertog Foundation Heritage Foundation
we're able to offer a supplemental
education in the great books in civics
in political philosophers that are not
covered at a lot of colleges there's a
demand for that we just have to fight
for that and if the left isn't going to
give our guys tenure we've got a fight
back harder we we shouldn't see them an
inch and we should continue to expand
our own academic programs because they
work and because there's a demand for
them and because those supplemental
academic groups lead to great changes
down the road this Cavanagh moment is
the perfect example of this because
forty years ago the federalist society
didn't exist
the idea of originalist judge is textual
textualist judges judges who actually
read the Constitution not just
constitutional law but the Constitution
what it meant publicly at the time that
it was ratified that was a radical novel
idea now you've got the federalist
society giving a list of two dozen
judges and we're just knocking them down
appellate judges we've got two Supreme
Court judges now from from that list
these can have a huge impact even
decades later so we should not see it an
inch they want us to but we shouldn't do
it before we go I know we're running out
of time I do have to talk about this
wonderful day am i talking about
indigenous people stay new I'm talking
about Columbus Day one of my favorite
holidays of the year Christmas Easter
Columbus Day it's very how can I rank
them how can I rank those days Columbus
Ohio named for the discoverer himself no
longer celebrates Columbus Day they
renamed it indigenous peoples day there
were programs in Los Angeles Seattle
cities across the country to rename
Columbus Day indigenous peoples day
which is absurd president Trump
recognizes the absurdity of this I wake
up today you know I kind of checked my
Twitter see what's going on and I see
President Trump tweeted this he said
quote Christopher Columbus's spirit of
determination and adventure has provided
inspiration to generations of Americans
on Columbus Day we honor his remarkable
accomplishments as a navigator
and celebrate his voyage into the
unknown expanse of the Atlantic Ocean
I'm about ready to abolish
the Congress and just named him
president for life can we if he has the
moral clarity to talk about how great
Christopher Columbus's get it to be the
number one trend on Twitter like I want
it to be Charles the second go in there
I am I abolish the Parliament I am the
king I'm I'm this close to that I'm not
quite there yet but I'm very very close
because it's absolutely right this
indigenous peoples day nonsense has come
up because of a fiction that the new
world was some orderly and peaceful and
probably utopian before European
settlers got there it's total nonsense
five years before Christopher Columbus
came to the new world shores the Aztec
empire slaughtered 84,000 people in the
course of four days for the consecration
of Tenochtitlan you know I guess if
you're gonna slaughter 80,000 people 10
Artie Glenn's a good reason to do it you
know that was five years before Columbus
arrived we were told Columbus brought
murder brought genocide brought rape
there was plenty of genocide going on
before then the suggestion that we named
the day after the indigenous peoples
which indigenous peoples are you going
to name it after you're gonna name it
after the Comanche about the Comanche
they're an indigenous people or will you
name it after the Apache from whom the
Comanche stole their land who are you
gonna name it are you going to name it
after the Caribbean Islanders which gave
us the word cannibal into our Western
languages because we discovered
cannibalism among vicious cannibals when
when Columbus pulled up and met the very
peaceful nice Taino Indians he noticed
that they had a lot of scars on their
body music these vicious warriors from
the isla de Caribe how about the
Iroquois Confederacy also cannibals by
the way oh well how about them should we
name are we going to name it after those
indigenous peoples they seemed pretty
warlike they seems pretty brutal pretty
savage who are you going to name it
after it's absurd now that question is
responded to often on the left and they
say well that's just what about ISM yeah
they might not have been good but
Columbus wasn't good either Columbus was
a genuinely wonderful man he was a great
man he was devoutly religious he was in
in many ways Carol Delaney has a great
book on this looking to create a crusade
to go retake the holy land because
Christians at the time thought that the
apocalypse was near
they saw the fall of Constantinople they
saw a lot of signs in the skies he
wanted to go over to the Great Khan in
the in the east you know the descendants
of Genghis Khan and convert those who
were not already converted to
Christianity and and also you know fund
all of these excursions with the gold
and spices and riches and a new trade
route yeah he said his prayers
constantly and the young sailors says
prayers constantly on the voyage he was
accused of his political rival Francisco
de Bobadilla of being brutal to the
Indians we have no evidence that that
actually happened in fact we have a lot
of evidence that Columbus was
particularly kind to the Native
Americans it would be like saying you
know Hillary Clinton wrote mean things
about Donald Trump so Trump was a
terrible guy no it was his political
rival you can't take that as gospel
truth and we know from bartolome de las
casas one of the great defenders of the
native peoples that columbus was
particularly kind to them in columbus
his own writings he complains about the
spaniards who were mean to the indians
and who would you know cut them up and
be brutal to them it was Columbus
perfect no of course not
he through in many ways the weakness of
his government he enslaved certain
native peoples he also adopted certain
native peoples though it raised as a son
of the son of a Indian friend that he
had made on one of his voyages so
obviously the reality is much more
complicated but I think the reality
points to a great man and more than
anything more than all of that even if
he were a mean guy which there's no
evidence that they were there was that
he was and there's a lot of evidence
that he was a very good guy
even if he were a mean guy he is the
reason that you're here he is the reason
the United States exists he is the
reason that the West came over here
settled the land made it improved the
agriculture improved the systems of
justice in this country and spread those
systems with justice around the world
led to the most prosperous charitable
free equitable just society in the
history of the world the world is so
much better off for this man having
lived it was the greatest navigator of
his age he was one of the bravest human
beings ever to walk the earth he led to
what the greatest civilization in the
history of the world he is a good guy
and in case
I haven't driven at home my feelings on
Christopher Columbus Tony Soprano take
it away they would make fine servants
with 50 men we could sub gate them
subjugate and make them do whatever we
want that doesn't sound like a slave
here to do George Washington had slaves
the father of our country well what's
your point his history teacher mr.
Cushman is teaching your son that if
Columbus was alive today he would go on
trial for crimes against humanity like
Milosevic and you know Europe your
teacher said that it's not just my
teacher it's the truth
it's in my history book so you finally
read a book in its book Tony I'll get
the book at Columbus his shoes to see
what he went through people thought the
world was flat for crying out loud then
he left under neither what a bunch of
naked savages on it I mean I took a lot
of guts you remember when we with the
flower to the heat and those bugs
well like it took guts to murder people
and put him in Chains he was a victim of
his time
uh who cares it's what he did he
discovered America is what he did he was
a brave Italian explorer and this house
Christopher Columbus is a hero
end of story on this show Christopher
Columbus is a hero
end of story absolutely right crack the
beers for Brett guzzle down your leftist
tears I will see you all tomorrow
in the meantime I'm Michael Knowles this
is the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you